we just heard from Robert generic there
um what was your reaction to what he was
saying I had you listening well he said
the British public expect a proper
system that is safe and fair that is not
what we have and today is Groundhog Day
because 18 months ago pretty Patel stood
up and said the Asylum system's broken
I've got a plan I'm going to fix it it's
got worse since then and we now have a
situation as we talked about in prime
minister's question time today we're
only four percent of the people who came
across on small boats last year have
been processed this is a problem of the
government's making because the delays
and are now so long the decision making
is so collapsed and the number of
returns is so low we're returning a
tenth of what we used to do that the
whole system is is an opportunity for
those criminal gangs to really exploit
people and to get them to this country
because what's going to happen they're
not going to be they're not going to
have their Asylum claim look tap for at
least a year and possibly not returned
even if they're turned down the whole
system is chaotic and that's where
criminal gangs are making the most of it
and exploiting people and people are
making those difficult dangerous
Journeys I take your point of course
about how long the conservatives have
been in power but this is a new
Administration under sunak he's got a
new immigration Minister as well who
acknowledged that the processing times
are not good enough but they are putting
more resources into trying to correct
that Robert gemrick also saying that
things are improving at manston and
they're on a path to a well-functioning
and legally compliant site within days I
mean I guess you can judge them in a few
days but if things do improve should you
give them any credit
would know the system has been broken
for a long time we've known this the
home Affairs select committee had a
really damning report back in July
saying look this is a huge problem the
number of people coming in is only going
to increase this is not some surprise
shift uh in what's happening we've seen
it coming and of course in Madison it's
been absolutely devastating and the
local MP has said
it was working fine in manston until
five or six weeks ago when the Home
Secretary he says took a policy decision
not to increase the number of hotels and
and therefore we've seen the big
increase of people and and children
sleeping on cardboard which is awful and
reports today that people have been
taken to Victoria Station and left there
not even given accommodation I mean the
whole thing is chaotic and it all comes
down to how the government seems
incapable of running anything uh
including the Asylum system do you know
anything more about this judicial review
who are you learning as we are I'm
learning as you are but I I'm not
surprised and we've said this is going
to cost the taxpayer money because you
can't break the law and put people in
those conditions and just ignore that
and allow that to happen of course there
are going to be implications of of
judicial reviews that that are going to
cost money the government should have
got a grip of this months ago actually
years ago and there are they are failing
to tackle the criminal gangs who are
driving this process they are failing to
do the administration yes because you
know I've heard you talk about uh
criminal gangs I asked you about Cooper
about Labor's plan to stop the small
boat she said it was all about criminal
gangs kirst armor again mentioning it at
pmqs it's very easy to say let's stop
criminal gangs everyone would agree with
that statement but it's very hard to do
it isn't it that's just classic
opposition politics I would say not all
uh let's look at where you put your
priorities so the government want to or
they have already spent 140 million
pounds on a Rwanda scheme that they
announced that hasn't happened and we
think will probably never happen
and doesn't work anyway uh instead of
spending the money on the Rwanda scheme
we would spend the money on the National
Crime agency having a new uh Workforce
there of people who can crack down on
those gangs now it's not easy I'm not
promising that it is but if you put the
resources there you make choices in
government about where you put your
money and where you put your priorities
we have to work with other countries
because we know that the criminal
networks are not just in the UK they're
across multiple countries so we have to
work with our allies on tackling it but
that's where we need the expertise the
National Crime agency is really good and
we know it's also at risk of being cut
under the new uh regime from Rishi sunak
so we we need to know that the
government is going to keep the resource
there but we would put more resourcing
is important but it is still very very
difficult you know I was really into
Interpol it says about these people
smuggling gangs low risk of detraction
and prosecution and arrest compared to
other activities of transnational organs
as crime they go on to say the
relationship between criminals and
migrants is very much a temporary one
making the criminals difficult to trace
they're generally unknown to the people
who are smuggling they hide behind
pseudonyms in encrypted chats use Rental
Vehicles different mobile phone numbers
you can put more money in that doesn't
mean that it's going to be easy to do
something but you can disrupt their
model and disrupting their model means
getting rid of a system that means that
if you get to the UK you'll be a year
before your assist your case is
processed and you might not be returned
even if you're turned down as an asylum
Seeker the criminal gangs can say
there's no other legal route this is
your only option you'll be in the UK for
at least a year it's worth spending your
money we need to disrupt that as well as
going after the criminal gangs